dude the ceo or the editor-in-chief for
sports illustrated should go and thank
jordan peterson they probably haven't
had that many clicks in ages
for [ __ ] sake i clicked on it i was
like oh [ __ ] the the this the swimsuit
edition is out let's see what's going on
here
i want to see who the woman is that he
thinks is is not attractive of course
i'm going to do that you know
it is so it is you're so right man like
they must be split testing what gets the
most clicks for this
the fashion companies that are using
plus size models you'll notice that they
never use skinny fat guys
so they'll have normal dudes oh my god
did you see this the other day so it was
so funny one of my guys one of my guy
mates tweeted this from the uk about how
it was um
different types of underwear one was for
men and one was for women and the women
was women of all sizes and the dudes
were shredded out of existence and it
was just like a comparison of the
women's underwear and the guys underwent
all of the guys were absolutely ripped
bro that kind of sucks dude
that kind of sucks like look i i guess
maybe it's not masculine of me but to to
have that be the standard for men and to
not be like hey it's accepting it's
acceptable for a man to do that because
hey look like
um someone you know said this the other
day and and it was a woman she said like
you know i sometimes misinterpret
this we can give as much [ __ ] as we want
to men because they're men you know it's
like we misinterpret it it's like they
should be able to handle that
you know we have looked at a society
where you know we look at through the
lens of the quote-unquote patriarchy and
so we
dude i've just put it in the chat have a
look have a look at this thing so have a
look at the difference between it's maya
and the women's the women's lingerie and
the guys lingerie wait this is the exact
same is this the same page or did they
cut it no this is the same page
[Laughter]
you know what what does that [ __ ] say
man what does it say
to to men it's like oh yeah like
you guys don't need to be babied at all
ever you don't need compliments you you
know oh your feelings are hurt well
you're a man can you tell for the people
that are just listening can you describe
the uh the image all right so look
so look we have the women of all sizes
on top uh we have women of all ages for
sure on top you know we have an older
lady on the right a couple older ladies
in the middle
and ethnicities as well
all ethnicities men shredded shredded
shredded chicken
absolutely dick skin peeled
uh okay well looks like we have
uh a couple different races here uh and
then shredded well no it's not a couple
of different races there's only one like
slightly caramel guy but that's the same
dude twice oh that's the same dude
twice
great homeboy in the middle is ready to
step on stage he's peeled out of his
mind yeah
this is not uh yeah the the acceptable
but this is interesting they have um
this is different brands so are they
pulling from
are these like meyer uh
models or what's the deal here i'm not
sure sometimes sometimes uh e-commerce
sites will have their they'll get
products from a bunch of different
brands then they'll shoot it in their
style right like asus does this asos has
asos models even though they might have
night clothes so it doesn't really
matter that it's different brands
this is [ __ ] up now how [ __ ] wild
is that
it's so blatant
but anyways to finish what i was saying
is just like this this idea that you
know this woman had brought this to my
my attention she's like you know i i do
tend to just not really give as much of
a [ __ ] about men's feelings because it's
always we're worried about we are
worried about women's feelings and a lot
of times we can brush it off and that is
a mistake that i've i've made and i try
not to make anymore and you know it's
the same thing here it's like well
we have to absolutely worry about body
dysmorphia in men because the moment
that men begin to think that their
bodies aren't as acceptable as they
could or should be they can develop
problems that
you know us they usher out into real
life
we've seen this in in bodybuilding in in
my world in fitness like
the people that are constantly
commenting on another dude's body
like they do have problems within their
their own worlds this isn't just men
towards women it could be women towards
women or men towards other men and it
happens a lot of men towards other men
but dude think about what what we said
on the last one which is slut-shaming
the amount of slut-shaming that goes
from women to women the amount of people
who are anti-abortion or pro-life
by and large it's women the vast
majority of uh comments that are done
about other women's appearances done
from women to women and yeah like
this is where the whole battle of the
genders thing yeah you can't you it
can't just be this thing where it's like
men
versus women or women members of women
or women versus men it really is
problematic and i it's so [ __ ] weird
it's like i had this realization on tick
tock
because it's like the gen z kids the
kiddos out there like you're noticing a
lot of women who are just like they
they're playing on it they're not
actually serious but they always
vocalize it's like having a crush on a
woman now like me women are much more
vocal about being sexually interested in
other women because of their disdain for
men in general because we have the men
versus girls girls versus you know i'm
sorry yeah men versus girls girls
whatever you know that that war going on
between the two of them it's just so
apparent and the same could be said
on the opposite side like the the the
idea of oh she's for the streets you
know what i mean like what's up i mean
the the i it's like um if a if a woman
you know does something that's [ __ ]
she's for the streets oh okay pick your
head pick your head up king like focus
on yourself yeah yeah yeah as it's
that's like the the meme language that
kind of surrounds it and they both have
their flaws you know but it's it's
it's always it's
for me the only reason i'm bringing it
up is because like i don't see that
changing
and i think you you told me this before
you like uh that's where you you have
your issues zac is that you call to
action a culture shift which is just
like an almost impossible task yes i do
that a lot on my videos i go i i wish as
a culture we could do this thing better
um or i'm pointing out this flaw in in
some sort of fitness charlatan and i'm
i'm wishing that we could do this thing
better and for some reason i forget what
your point was or who brought it to your
attention but it's like calling to
action this massive cultural shift is
not always the answer it's not even
remotely the answer it will never work i
just don't think that it's realistic
because you don't have like a god's eye
coordination for this you know what you
would need to do would be able to sit
everybody down
and say look
here are some interesting insights guys
and girls about where you think your
oppression or your vulnerability or your
difficulties come from and a lot of them
are calls that are coming from inside of
your own [ __ ] house right women who
will
for the most part presume that i would
guess if you were to do a survey of
women they would think that slut-shaming
anti-abortion rhetoric and body shaming
mostly comes from men
it doesn't it comes from women and guys
like most of the guys that are having
the piss taken out of them about the way
that they look are about how strong they
are about how noodly their arms are and
stuff that
it's not girls that are saying that it's
your bros it's your bro friends or the
people that aren't even your friends
right like
that's where the vast majority of
attention but this gender war thing that
we've got that's going on at the moment
it gets clicks right because it creates
an easy in-group and out group you know
maybe after race it's the most prevalent
in and most obvious in-group and out
group that there is
yeah and then you know you would you
would assume that is part of like the
you know the non-binary discussion as
well you can create in-group out group
easily there well there's a million
different in-groups and out groups if
you do that what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you